una nota que arriba de la capital de kenia
que compro la vida de al menos uno
persona informada autoridad lluviosa
en un momento que se exalta en
alegna la reunión del país de
usted es precisamente para discutir nuevos
sanción enfrentamientos rojos a la guerra
continúa equipo de italia en un momento
crucial para quién en el lugar o si
nos encontramos en la región del parque
blart i bod sale con mayor
frecuencia y la noche si tambien la sirena
santier el ambiente evoluciona para rodar
de la situación especialmente
inestable en la zona del delta norte ha
razon tambien tambien sahin reactivo a
los lucha en el sur en particular es
el salvador de los ríos ocupados
pero entre puerto en el serkan regiona del
donbass a fuentes británica anna ha
firmó que la casa de severo donés
eso si cumple con el maco completo o
echa un vistazo a otros más allá de moscú
constituye una importante victoria de la
rusia esta libre de errar si teme por uno
ruptura de la línea de defensa ucraniana
e nesta sono i che tambien o tra
localidad de la que también es nueva
interiormente en la mano de los otros patmos
culo plan luego sufrir el mimo
destino y dias con la proxima semana